hello welcome back to big is a mood in
here
and today we are going to talk about
something that a lot of you have
requested of us especially you single
folk out there who feel perpetually
single is how do I trap a man and/or
woman and what the [ __ ] did you do to
trap your your person your significant
other like talking to a dude and like
just move really really like it we're
like trap him he's got good qualities
like health insurance understand that
whole thing like what do you mean okay
so some of us are married some of us are
in relationships and some of us are
dating around which i think is a really
nice well-rounded perspective you know
what we are different styles I guess we
got it we got it
married married like newly single in a
relationship and then question mark yeah
it does whatever the [ __ ] she wants yeah
let's see if I still you know I don't
know and we do mean whatever the [ __ ]
so Gina what is your freakin style how
do you first begin to trap a man right
okay so all right then I guess I could
say uh I'm very um insanely confident
you know yeah that helps a lot sometimes
intimidatingly so yeah I was actually
dated a guy well I mean like we were
trying to get to know each other and he
told me he's like I don't think I can
date you I'm like why he goes I fly
coach
Oh Gina huh small dick energy was small
dick energy because I owned that coach
seat yeah and then slap it on the tape
it's like I I have my luxurious side but
also chicken nuggets and some sweet sour
she did and then I was like wait what
are you trying to say you guys like
you're your designer bags and like you
fly first class you're gonna make fun of
me exactly she didn't want to trap that
guy though I know at first I did and
then I got a good job right I think I
heard about yeah and I kind of was like
there's something you're very um what
happened was he told me like oh yeah
this one program really changed my life
I was like what's it called he goes
landmark I was like oh the pyramid scale
oh my gosh
and then like it teaches you how to be a
better person like if you're gonna force
what I will say is that multi-level
marketing isn't always join a
multi-level marketing what the molle
yeah landmark is a [ __ ] cult are they
just glaze over their eyes just [ __ ]
glaze over they're like let me tell you
about books yeah it's like I don't I
don't need it by if you did that to have
a better life maybe you're not like
you're more of a beta than I thought you
know do things because we did you find
out about landmark before or after he
showed you his small dick and then he
like he sat down one day and he was just
like I I can't do this I'm like alright
I guess so I mean like and then I first
was like what why and then I realized
people like dating powerful women for
only like four weeks or so and then
they're like oh no I can scale it yeah
you're gonna wash my balls into a little
tiny blue how else have you trapped
actually trapped someone you wanted mmm
I make it known that I don't need you oh
wait so let's pretend like first of all
what type of guy do you go after
traditionally um I like ambitious okay
yeah I like him like so you like people
that are hard to trap because you're
like ooh I need a chase yeah
so I like strong I like sharks is what
it is yeah Mark Cuban that ass like
lawyers yeah yeah I like sharks because
so here's the thing I tend to steamroll
people if they're miss overs mm-hmm
because at first I thought I needed to
date someone that was like okay like
yeah there can't be two alphas in this
because we're gonna butt heads but then
I realize if I steamroll you I'm gonna
kind of start losing what you don't
respect yeah yeah yeah and I'm not
attracted to you anymore and I can tell
when I start steamrolling someone
because if we get into an argument
I usually don't argue I have discussions
but if i steamroll you it's more like
like Nikki you'll say like well I don't
really like it when you do that and I'll
be like well what do you want me to do
you want me do this then how about you
do this then you know so I need someone
who's like my equal that's like that a
little bit yeah because I need to be put
in my place yeah yeah I mean honestly
that's I feel like Steven as dynamic
like well he'll I'll pick at him and
they'll hope by back and I'm like yeah
my flirting techniques it's just like
really aggressive like I remember I told
this guy he's after a little while of
dating I was like I'm gonna make you
fall in love with me oh my god I like
that he's like okay ma'am
what's your go-to like trick up your
sleeves and make him fall in love I feel
like she's trapping guys with her
confidence confidence I've told people
straight up like I will completely
consume your life if you are not very
headstrong and resilient I will
completely consume your life way uh
because this is how it works out right
jeana's at first very confident very
aggressive dope whatever like that's
cool like I like a powerful women a
woman right and then they see my soft
side and then they're like oh my god you
know like my little baby soft side and
then there's looks like I want to
protect you and
that's when I consume them Wow right you
eat them from the inside out yeah and
then there's like I I want to take care
of you and I love that because I like
being a little baby yeah I know and then
like I warn people all the time and this
has happened in the past to where the
guy I'm seeing is like I don't want to
do anything else but just like spend my
time with you I haven't gone to the gym
in weeks
like I'm I'm neglecting everything and I
tell people I'm like yeah suck their
life energy they leave it back they
leave you of being like a bag of bones
muscles anymore scary I've been called
that so that's why I always like at
first like oh no it's not gonna happen
to me I'm like yeah yeah it's like a
challenge yeah take till they're there
like a month or two oh [ __ ] that's bad
yeah but then like I read them out by
who can actually take it yeah um one guy
that I was seeing for a long time he was
like he didn't understand how to live
with that and he kind of blamed it on me
like I I don't want to do this and I
don't wanna do that I'm like I'm not
making you stay home yeah I don't tell
them to do any of this this is your
choice you don't give a list of require
man yeah exactly
I'm pretty easygoing um but when I see
someone who can like actually balance
their life and actually like hold me off
for a little bit I'm like okay I think
this is good like yeah you do need an
alpha then I do yeah for sure because
then those are the ones that will
protect you to little baby my god like a
filthy businessman that like you can't
pull one over on because he'll be like
actually Gina lawyers dude but how do we
trap these alpha men well Bo they're
hard to trap how did you trap no I I
feel like I stumbled on my trapping
technique accidentally I I read this
this like study one time and it was
about so so worried I read this study
one time where secrets by the way yes
these are all the hot series I guys now
you know how you're getting trapped but
like it's not I mean it's not on purpose
it's just us you know but I read
something one time where they were
talking about it was like the
cheerleader effect we're in high school
the the football guy dates the
cheerleader cheerleader dates the like
head
shot guy and it's because they believe
they're investing in each other they're
like oh you're at the tippy-top you're
gonna be at the tippy-top and whatever
you do but then the jock doesn't get a
job and the girl continues to be this
tip-top woman and then eventually
they're not on the same path like they
feel as though they're almost investing
in each other and am I because I'm like
always so like busy like I literally
work a very busy nine-to-five just like
in April I got I got a nice little
office and nine oh two one oh with my
[ __ ] name on the door like that's I'm
honestly so proud of that because I when
I was a kid when I first started using
Neopets this is just like a random sorry
I'm so proud of this [ __ ] I started
using Neopets right and my mom was
scared of the Internet so she didn't
want me to put my real address on
anything when I registered and you're
the city always had to match the zip
code because it would like cross-check
it and the only other zip code I knew
was nine oh two one oh so I would always
type nine oh two one oh like four online
as I'll [ __ ] live for years and years
and years and then one day when I was at
work and I was having a package shipped
and I put the zip code in as 9:02 one no
I was like but I'm not
years later nothing crazy but I mean
like yeah in this past year I've got
this [ __ ] I've got this amazing job
I've got this sick podcast in business
with you guys oh yeah I started a
production company like last November
with a good friend of mine I pick up a
lot of side projects I'm like I try to
stay very connected and I'm always
updating my boyfriend on what I'm doing
like not like to flex or anything I'm
just like you're my partner and I'm
sharing this with you and he's not going
anywhere because where am I gonna be in
five years at the tippy toes watching
you like your best self yeah he you
don't if you know like it's like if you
were dating like an actor or something
and you know that he just got cast in
this huge role in the movie comes out in
two years you're like let me hold on to
this [ __ ] mind my P's and Q's here it's
almost like you're investing so like
sometimes when you're very ambitious and
you're accomplishing a lot of things
people that also are that similar
mindset like my boyfriend is very
ambitious he's like okay she's gonna be
where I'm at in five years and I know
that he's gonna we're gonna be on the
same playing field in five years 10
years 15 years and we motivate each
other so like I kinda like I kind of
like try to kill it so that like he
knows that I'm worth waiting for and
worth making it work for like I try to
prove that I'm worth it so your style of
trapping a guy is just being 100%
awesome where are they gonna go yeah
we're gonna go to 99% us yeah yeah I
like it like you I don't know it's but I
I know that I know that I like all of it
like sometimes when I'm like having it
like low self-esteem day I'll straight
up text them cuz if I need something
I'll tell you and I texted em and I'll
be like tell me something nice about me
tell me something you like about me
and nine times out of ten what he'll
tell me is you're so [ __ ] driven and
then whole like list out all of the [ __ ]
that like I'm doing and like I know he
appreciates it and like it's such a
funny contrast because I remember five
years ago I was head over heels for this
guy it was a dude I [ __ ] met online
but like we were we would always talk I
had such a big crush on him and like I
wanted I would always be like oh I'm
gonna come see you oh I can come see you
and I'm like oh I can come any day I had
nothing
going on I literally had nothing going
on Oh and and that is not attractive
available yeah yeah able like cute comes
off as needy in case people are
wondering late cuz I used to be that
same way I'm like what do you mean I'm
just there for them like I didn't wanna
hang cuz I like them like so I think
some guys kind of test you to they'll
ask you to like come over like multiple
times you know like in like they do want
you to come over right but then also
they're gonna kind of start losing a
little bit of respect whenever you never
push knock like oh I'm busy it's just
some okay I'm there I'm there I'm there
I'm there kind Wes they make if every
single request to make send me nudes do
this do that you you fulfill every
single request they make they're like
she's too [ __ ] easy yeah I have a
hard line of like my life and it's also
like I don't want to see it's like I
don't need you attitude because I go
motional e behind closed doors like you
but outside of it like I I could you
know walk away and like we would both be
fine you know yeah it'll dance to it
yeah house look like building the inside
of you first you know like just like
really knowing who you are like what
like what you won't settle for and
that's awesome yeah what are you doing
lately what you've been up to
there's a lot going on it's like there's
a lot happening I think I usually trap
men by using comedy and sex
that's your sound dude oh my god still
there though like if someone were to
combine all of us like super confident
super busy [ __ ] funny and good in bed
like that is a danger oh yeah Power
Ranger yeah mega Swartz's combined power
rangers yeah it's like the homemaker and
then like a wonderful mom like clone us
all of us dude so yeah I mean like I
think everyone at this point knows the
story of how I trap Joe we were texting
for like a month and I said you should
come to Texas for barbecue and sex and
it was a joke but it was comedy and it
was sexual and it worked on him I think
just kind of like with guys too like
they just they want to go into
situations feeling like okay like we can
have fun it's gonna be cool like I don't
have to immediately throw my whole life
away or invest every single [ __ ]
thing for you like let's just hang out
and have fun and like if you kind of
give them the space to be like we're
just gonna get to know each other we're
gonna have fun while we do it
it could only last three weeks it can
last six weeks it could last a few
months but like we're gonna just enjoy
that time together if it doesn't work
out it's fine I think a lot of girls go
into it like okay I've already invested
three weeks we have to make this work
like what's going on and if you know
like if he pulls away for like two days
or something then they're like oh my god
what's happening like so you you can't
really trap a man with too much force
it's almost like you have to step back a
little bit and give him space and you
will trap himself that's actually how
Casey and I started dating cuz like I
told him I'm like hey I just got out of
a very serious relationship I'm not
trying to get in one I'm just trying to
have fun you get my drift so we just had
like exactly I'll give you space sure
and then you're like I need no gas oven
exactly so cuz then I even told him I'm
like listen because we had already every
single time we saw each other we were
having sex I wasn't saying he tried hurt
and then no then I told him Oh
yeah he does but um but you know I said
at one point I was like hey listen it's
okay you know you can run away I got a
lot of baggage it's cool I'm not like
I'm not trippin like you don't have to
commit to this there's a lot to commit
to like we're we said we were just
having fun and he was like no I want you
I want this I want you and I'm like see
that's how I trapped you I told you and
you decided to stay but obviously I'm
coerced a confession well see you got
got dude you did the same to me Wow
freaking [ __ ] he played hard to get
and it actually worked I was like damn
it because he was playing these stupid
ass games at you looking back now I get
so mad at past if I'm like why the hell
did you oh yeah but like for example he
would do things like like oh let's meet
up at 7:00 p.m. he won't show up till
like he loved it and I'm like [ __ ]
hate that and I still put up with put
out with it well it's not like he
treated me like that so I had exes that
treated me like that were they it was
almost manipulative like what you were
saying they were testy Steve genuinely
like he thinks he's on time and is not
just like oh wait I was just reading
read it and yeah I'm leaving right now
yeah he's just at his computer still
like and he doesn't understand that time
goes by or if I'm like hey we got to be
at this place by 2:00
he will start getting ready at 1:55
innocent because Kasey was not innocent
about it he was she knew what the [ __ ]
he was doing cuz instead of coming and
meeting me up at 7 p.m. he was having
lunch with some other girl oh and I'm
like you said you weren't seeing anyone
else he cuz like I know that we're not
trying to be exclusive yet at that time
it's just like well we're having fun but
I'm like I'm not seeing anyone and I
asked you if you were seeing anyone you
said you weren't but then I find out you
were and you stay in standing me up for
so that's really a rose in our
relationship
because he was good in bed and you know
what else is good in bed
Buffy Bose what is a Buffy you're in for
a treat
y'all you know I love this comforter and
Buffy's watching send me another one I
need it for me my mom my man everybody
everybody needs the comforter I was just
thinking I'm getting kind of tired I
can't wait to go back to bed and like
I'm thinking about the comforter I'm
posting it oh my man Nikki got one oh
when you go back you know it's
underrated also as their sheets and
duvet sets I know it's not on there but
they make the [ __ ] best yeah it's me
over her house and she has the the
covers and everything and I was just
like I'm never leaving your bed ever
guys Buffett makes super soft earth
friendly bedding because a company
night's sleep is even comfier when it
doesn't harm the environment I know
y'all are all green George Green us
immediately Nikki in the plan love it we
love it Buffy makes the Earth's most
comfortable bedding everything is made
from ultra smooth eucalyptus fiber that
feels softer than cotton it feels like
you're sleeping on a freakin cloud the
eucalyptus fiber there is breathable
cool to the touch to help maintain ideal
sleeping temperature without without
overheating all of their products are
cruelty free and hypoallergenic feel
like I don't do the comforter justice
paper but I also gotta keep it PG you
know so got it it's that good it's a
very good comforter that's a code how do
I get this comfort well first of all you
should take up your free trial because
Buffy offers a free trial you can try a
comforter in your own bed for free and
if you don't like it you can return it
at no cause but just if you want it for
$20 off of your Buffy comforter you can
visit Buffy Co and enter mood
that's right or $20 off your Buffy
comforter visit Buffy CEO and inter mood
ood but do 20 books that's a lot oh yeah
oh yeah the huge estes cancer saving and
you know what else you could find
discounts with is a honey online
shopping is supposed to be easy y'all so
why it's still hard to find these
discount codes on the in person they
just send them to you in the mail and
then online you got to get them in an
email why I got a sign-up for a club for
I want to do all that and then when I
google on the codes don't work but guess
what honey solves all of that for you
it's a browser extension that with a
click of a button you just save money
you could have you could have a cart for
a hundred bucks and it'll just randomly
give you free delivery a 20% off coupon
whatever they have that is active honey
has been around for a while
it's trusted and it works you can shop
on any of your favorite sites some that
they have our Target Best Buy Sephora
Macy's eBay Etsy Walmart you could
literally buy like my whole Google
search history yes yes yes Lord I just
bought a 50-inch TV from Walmart and I
used a honey coupon on top and it was
loves 10% but that's still pretty good
yeah yeah hundreds of dollars hallelujah
hallelujah so honey has found over 18
million members over two billion dollars
in sicko that's right but beautiful
Ottoman not using honey is literally
just losing yourself free money it's
free to use and installs in just two
clicks so get honey for free at join
honey calm slash mood that's join honey
calm slash mood all right and we're back
so trapping trapping where were we yes
what about me oh yeah and then him being
a jerk he trapped me I was trapped in is
a little weird
it really is who do you feel like
trapped trapped to in your relationship
because it's almost like I feel like
it's the same like they kind of trapped
each other and I can almost feel like
you guys trapped each other
I'm a combination of you and Gina mmm
like 100% sex I'll is Gina yes and and I
also found that I like alpha males I
didn't know that I didn't know they were
alpha males they just have a certain
energy big-dick energy um that I yeah
that I find really attractive that
confidence and that like if I poke them
they poke me back and I'm like oh I kind
of like that that's hot and like we make
each other laugh so then like sex and
comedy really worked for me when I was
dating and I think that did we trapped
each other with that for sure like where
we really had the same sense of humor -
yeah an umpteenth degree and it's really
hard to find someone that just like hits
that humor spot and remember both of us
and yeah our first date we missed the
movie three times because we couldn't
stop talking and make each other laugh
and like roasting each other busting
balls and like eating sushi and it was
just all around a great time and I feel
like um I feel like I'm most like you
and you were saying the thing about you
know they see your aggressive side and
then they like see your soft side and
they want to take care of you so that
for me like I love being like a little
baby getting taken care of because I
have this huge sentimental soft side
especially with the emotional stuff and
Steve thrives off taking care of so I
see that a very nurturing friend yeah
even as a friend like anyone can text
him at any time he's so down to like
have to our conversations with someone
and like dude great listen he's gonna be
a great dad
I know I ovaries are gonna go already
every time I see him with like our
nieces and nephews they just light up
like they're just
I wanna bubble in yeah we're trying like
playing with his niece and nephews one
day like we were at like a family
cookout thing and I never have been like
I want kids but I he was really good
with them and I literally like just got
lost and watching and then I realized I
was like Fanning myself
he was like throwing the ball with one
kid and then like moving this little
truck thing around the other one you
know I think that's a biological thing I
was reading that like you know how they
say that like a lot of women are
attracted to married men or if they see
that wedding ring they like immediately
more attractive yeah and it's and also
if they see a man with a child and
they're like really good with your kid
it's like immediate attraction and it's
this biological thing that's like oh I
can procreate and we will be safe yeah
just visual proof one thing happen to me
well I don't get like well that's
because you're married so you really
shouldn't be attracted to them before
like because Casey actually wasn't good
with Isaac like initially he wasn't like
you were like I want to trap that [ __ ]
he's not good with my kids just like
well the thing is that's when I'm saying
like it was just [ __ ] weird with us
because we gave a lot of I really did I
really overlooked a lot take thank you
good it was just too good but um but
yeah like he would act really weird and
uncomfortable around Isaac and I was
very conscious would I do it yeah it was
upside down no he was just very like oh
I just like I don't know how to deal
with the kid and for me I was very
conscious of like he is my
responsibility
like don't worry you could but if he was
really good with Isaac don't you think
that would have like warmed your heart a
little bit
yeah but I'm saying like it that wasn't
the offender yeah
it wasn't necessary Oh totally yeah and
I guess me neither
I never saw a Steve with a kid or him
with like a wedding ring obviously but I
did see him in a serious relationship so
I don't know if that counts but we were
both in serious relationships at the
same time and he treated his girlfriend
like how I wanted my boyfriend to treat
me and vice versa and so we kind of saw
each other's relationship styles and
both of us are super loyal and when
we're in a relationship we don't like
see your flirt with anyone else and like
I don't even have no desire they're all
like blobster yeah but as soon as we
both got dumped like both of us worthy
dumpees
yeah they're they I would never write
never dumped so we like ate like open to
the door like the cloud came off of him
and I was like whoa a potential mate and
that was really attractive that he was
so good to his girlfriend Nikki I feel
like you have some really special
insight on how to trap your best friend
oh yeah oh yeah because yeah I started
out as friend
we did yes he was definitely
friend-zoned we were both friends owned
with each other a great foundation by
the way totally recommend Steve on for
how to get out of the friendzone
because you you kind of started you
already wrote I wish I could have a
boyfriend like Steve green I was already
kind of like in her diary I said I won't
settle until I find someone exactly like
Steve green because I knew that was out
there I just thought he was a template I
didn't think I was gonna get you I don't
know that's funny because how long did
you and Steve know each other before you
started three years so in that three
years you guys got two seats and like
you were in close friend groups you guys
got to see like every little bit of each
other whereas in dating relationships
sometimes you're like oh I like this
person I kind of want to hide certain
bits of me
hold on I'll see if they accept them
later but you and Steve kind of got to
see a 360 view of each other and so
going into it you knew like you're what
I want oh yeah and I was like I hope
that wasn't just a facade like I like
okay I'm gonna find out on this date the
first date if that was all just
something I built up in my mind like
it's
an image that he put out but no 100%
real deal and I was like yes this is it
I can't believe it was so easy that like
that would click so fast but it was
because of that history and even better
when we were both in each other's friend
zone you know he tried so much like I'm
almost overcompensating to show like
he's not attracted to me because we're
both in relationships you know [ __ ]
gross
yeah I'd wait for anything yes got away
from me I don't want this sorry yes
that's how it was because like they were
all it was all guys and then me and then
sometimes his girlfriend here and there
but you know it was a lot of guys and
all of them were in relationships and so
they'd almost like go over the line
being like you're just a little sister
like you're just like you're not
sexually attractive at all how did you
guys even go on a first date then so
then he not knows a date I didn't know
you didn't know yeah because he had just
gotten broke up broken up with two weeks
prior and I felt like that was not
enough time to heal for a four-year
relationship so I did not want to be a
rebound I did not want it to be just
like a fast thing like that even though
I eventually wanted to sneak into those
dams but I slipped it to his best friend
to kind of like hey I like put feelers
out there for me and he immediately told
Steve and and then Steve like asked me
out
well like he asked me out on when we
were filming a sketch but it wasn't like
hey will you go on a date with me it was
like hey have you seen this movie it was
the the what is it the Great Gatsby and
I was like no I heard it sucks but I
still want to see it just to see for
myself if it sucks and he's like yeah me
too we should see if it sucks together
totally here's Steve saying this right
there so then I was filming a video with
my other friend that was in that same
sketch group so we had all been friends
together and he had been roommates with
Steve before and I was like hey so he
asked me like this do you think that's a
date or like like how should I treat
this should I expect anything is it just
us being friends now that we're both
single we can like kind of like hang out
one-on-one or you know what is it what
do you think it is and he was like no
it's definitely not a date it's been too
soon like
up with and I was like that's what I was
thinking so he's like okay if he brings
up his ex like a bunch of times then it
don't count it as a date yeah and I was
like okay yeah because I'm so used to
being just friends with him that it was
weird like seeing him in any sort of
romantic light at all like like imagine
right now like he's everyone's friend
like like switching that gear to like oh
now he's in a romantic light was so it
was just so different you know yeah and
he let me know immediately before the
date before he picked me up he's like
hey by the way you don't have to do
anything I'm paying for food I'm picking
you up no I was like oh it's a date yeah
put a dress on he also saved my life I
almost fell down an entire flight of
stairs like concrete stairs and feel
like like literally like Superman I have
you fair maiden for you guys it was like
a you know we're kind of in the friend
zone but it was almost like it was meant
to be anyway so there's really no
trapping that needed to be done you do
have the right time in place true like
we said our traps and I'm like you want
to walk me what about like how would you
want a like what about how to trap a
girl so like what works for you like
when a guy oh like oh do you guys know
like what really works for you me but
did TIFF see how she trapped Casey well
I mean they kind of talked about and I
don't even know how we're married trap
do you know how you eat that chance me
oh man I must i'd love what are you a
sucker for I like getting taken care or
like arrogance oh I'm up there too you
know like I'm kind of a [ __ ] too you
know and I like that I like someone
who's kind of the same as me it kind of
understands but also really funny like
we're not super serious like arrogant
yeah that's fun where's like kind of
like I know I'm this [ __ ] yeah like
super super serious yeah
and on the ship but also please little
spoon me you know I think you have
awareness so it's like it's not like Oh
II go that gets to your head and you
don't see anything bad about you or
whatever it's like this confidence
that's kind of like yeah that could be a
brat whatever of all time bratty Hoos
and then like he'll just be like
[ __ ] me - what are you gonna do
about like on the date like what kind of
date would help move it along I like
really good conversationalist
you know yeah like obviously I mean
that's pretty obvious with anyone right
Oh kind of conversations though anything
and everything like the best dates I've
ever had were the ones just like we
would go out and we just talk for like
six hours and we're just like oh my god
we have so much in common this is wild
and they're super funny and then it's
like if it's that natural if I never
feel like I have to work like this just
you know it just happens like I'm just
like oh man okay you're memorable you
know a lot of like some of my best
relationships were the ones where we
start off as in yes probably not gonna
be anything or like I can't stand you
and afterwards it's like yeah I'm
suspecting ones yeah yeah beause dude I
feel like mine's gonna sound really
[ __ ] up but there's a reason why I
need to be like taking care of like my
love language is not really gifts but
like if you pay for dinner if you like
buy me [ __ ] I I'm I'm a very very
anxious person I worry about like the
future a lot and I grew up with not a
lot of money so it is it is very very
important for me that like I can eat and
then I know that I can eat and so for me
when a guy like takes care of me with a
lot of stuff it's not that like I'm
greedy and I want his money I feel like
safe I feel a sense of safety that I
didn't feel when I was younger and not
sure yeah like I I don't like I feel
like there's a quote or something like
that where people say like some people
want to feel like to never want for
anything and I don't want my brains to
be clouded with oh I want this I wish I
could eat this tonight bla bla bla
because I'm able to think a lot more
clearly and since I've gotten my
finances in order
it's just taking a lot of stress off of
my plate so when a guy is able to
provide for me I think that could be
universally said for every woman I I
think so because I told human nature it
really is because I totally relate to
that because Casey it really did turn me
on that he wasn't like fussy about money
because I had dated other people that
like I could like I would have to pay
the [ __ ] bills or like I'd have to
pay for dinner yep and I was like yuck I
mean some women are like don't pay for
me you think I can't take care of myself
you know what feels like a gift in the
mail every month
clothes picked out for you via a style
quiz and then having a box sent to you
with exactly that style I found a great
service called stitch fix calm and holy
balls can I say balls holy balls because
if you do not know your style it is
really hard to shop and a lot of us out
there are just amateurs trying to shop
for our own bodies not knowing what the
hell looks good on our on our models own
nothing and which dish fix it takes away
all of the guesswork you go on to the
website you take a little style quiz you
you mark the ones that you like it that
you don't like and then from that an
actual professional stylist puts
together outfits that they think you
would look good in and guess what I look
damn good in them I got a package full
of a bunch of clothes that I might not
have picked out if I was shopping for
myself and they all look so good I feel
so cute after entire box cake yeah I
entire box you know you know and you
know what if you keep your entire box
you get a discount oh yeah you get a
there's a there's a styling fee but if
you keep your whole box that styling fee
goes towards your purchase so it's
basically the stylist was free imagine a
free personal stylist that's crazy
those cost so much oh my god I got the
most comfortable pair of jeans from
comfortable
yeah so they make the booty pop with
stitch fix booty wearing booty wearing
jeans accessories including brands you
know and love as well as exclusive
styles that you won't find anywhere else
you can do it with no subscription
required you could pick between
automatic
shipments or you can get new pieces
on-demand shipping exchanges and returns
are always free which is dope because it
feels like ooh
what if I don't like it you know it's
it's safe you can return it if you don't
like it's all but you're probably gonna
like it
plus the $20 styling fee is
automatically applied towards anything
you keep from your box so get started
today at stitch fix calm
slash mood and get an extra 25% off
that's a quarter of the total when you
keep everything in your box which I did
that's six fix calm slash mood stitch
fix calm slash mood if you don't want to
go and leave your house to get clothes
why would you want to leave your house
to get food yeah I don't know what else
for anything no you get a long day at
work tough day at school
still stuck it could help me Nikki door
- can help you so you keep your
sweatpants on or whatever clothes you're
styling in and door - will connect you
to your favorite restaurants in your
city ordering is easy you just use the
door - app and you choose what you want
to eat and add a shirt we'll bring it to
you anywhere that you are there's over
3,300 40,000 amazing restaurants and
door - connects you with door-to-door
delivery in over 3300 cities and states
including Canada I know it's not a state
but it's just like it might as well be
it's like having a boyfriend on it hall
that brings you food or girlfriend or
girlfriend yeah so nice yeah you don't
don't worry about dinner
I love that yeah it's restaurant quality
food with a living room dress code you
don't have to ever worry about dressing
up just to get your food from the door
but what if I can't get my favorite food
you can because they can execute all of
your favorites
Chipotle you got it you want Cheesecake
Factory
it's your the only problem you're gonna
have is selecting what to eat it too
many options like they really should
just tell you what you need but right
now our listeners can get five dollars
off their first order of $15 or more
when you download the door - app and
enter promo code big mood big mood
that's five dollars off your first order
when you download the door - app from
the App Store and enter promo code big
mood moving mood don't forget that's
promo code big mood for five dollars off
your first order from door - big mood
thank you tour -
okay so I thought about something okay I
realize it what I like is because I'm
also the same way with the gifts I like
it when he's just like man kind of an
[ __ ] and aggressive to everyone else
yeah but to me yeah treats me like a
little baby like a little something
because I'm the same way like you guys
know how I am
yeah is that right I love that about you
yeah very aggressive somewhat kind of
mean when I need to be but I like I like
to be babied and I liked being the one
that you know he he sweets me like how I
am with you guys I mean everyone else
but I you know yeah yeah baby is and I
love that I love what he's just like
I'll see him out there just like oh
Power Move yeah yeah and then I'm just
like baby Yoda baby Yoda is your spirit
animals people don't realize this I have
a really really soft gooey inside yeah
and I don't like to have that seen my
fans think I'm a thug I think that's
what trapped me as a friend with Eugene
I could never leave because when we
first met like immediately you're like
well I guess this goes into the first
impression stuff but like I thought that
you were gonna be one of those like oh
I'm pretty so I'm gonna be a [ __ ] to
every other girl that I see in the room
because I can only be the pretty one
like that kind of girl that's what I
thought of you yeah because you're just
so pretty it's all like and then you do
have like oh very like you can be scary
so like Danny immediately wants you and
I started connecting and then I remember
I complimented you on a piece of jewelry
I think it was a ring and you just took
it off your hand and gave it to me oh my
god I love you we're so welcoming yeah
show it but I love to love you really do
don't you [ __ ] tell anyone all right
but similar to you bows what you're
talking about just like being taken care
of and like feeling like secure and that
um I didn't realize because I'm not
gifts but I'm acts of service and I
didn't realize that that was really my
thing because Steve was kind of the
first person to like really do that
because I feel like I put off this like
you know I'm independent and I really do
value that or value of like getting
things done and the way I like them and
I felt you like paying for all my own
stuff and you know yeah that's that's
kind of why gifts was never like my
personal love language however I get
super stressed out and overwhelmed and
it made me so happy to like when Steve
came in and was like let me do it how
you like it to be done service yes of
service and it's similar to gifts where
like they're giving you something
they're giving you your time and energy
and they're taking care of something for
you that like was on my plate that no
longer has to be on my plate and I don't
have to worry about it being like okay
but is it gonna be like the way that I
like it and you make sure to fold the
corners like that and you know you have
these like perfectionistic qualities but
then if they learn that and they really
take the time to observe and learn it
that [ __ ] melts my heart I'm like I
just want you forever for the rest of my
life there's this one guy who set an
alarm on his phone to go back and get
the teddy bear that he's told me hugging
while we were walking I [ __ ] died
dude yeah that's how Steve what so I was
like a broke-ass [ __ ] when I first met
him it was like right after I got sued a
lot of another story yeah it was a bad
time in my life but it was lewisham who
is it he he who is he oh I was his name
was he can't just say that because it's
an NDA I'm good for you I mean not like
that but I'm gonna come kuna yeah get
him Gina but yeah so I was kind of
embarrassed when I first started dating
cuz he was the first guy to ever pay for
dinner or or like buy me anything and he
did he did things like that cuz I would
never ask for something to be bought
because I felt like [ __ ] mad at myself
you know but yeah I would try on like
these leggings and I feel like oh man I
wish I could get those I'm like okay
I'll save my money and like I'll we told
this day or whatever and he would
surprise me in the trunk with it like
we'd go to
like I gotta go to the bathroom and he
like put it in the car and surprise me
with it what the [ __ ] I love you I love
that yeah I think we have to SEMA love
lingual yeah exercise service yeah
you're curious like how would somebody
trapped you know Jess Eileen even you're
a wild horse neighing around all horses
I like different things at different
times of my life so you kind of have to
just like be the the interesting flavor
of the year I guess Wow
so I really can't be trapped from know I
can well not for life with like Evan lo
with her baby I think you I think you
can almost always be trapped by a laughs
daddy like if somebody's like me yeah
laughs I feel yeah well so I okay I'm
not gonna get too deep into it because I
don't want to take say too many details
but I have gone on two dates deep
intimacy from from an app that we are
actually sponsored by and I have two
dates and so comparing those to one of
them I was more interested in and I
guess I could go into maybe why like one
worked more than the other so I guess
that's like he kind of he's not really
trapped me because we're not like
together but one was more so he has two
other interests he has trapped my enjoy
now because Ron Davis so the first one
that did not work out too well I felt
like so first of all he lied about his
age so don't lie on dating apps about
your age because that's really [ __ ]
weird
no but it was really weird though to lie
about it on the app and then meet up and
just come clean about it like that's
then what's the point of lying in the
first yeah so weird tall he was and of
course like he had to come clean about
it when we met in person what other
choice do you have
well yeah I'd be wearing those like
sneakers that have like really laughing
like a four inch platform on the sneaker
they already used to photoshop herself
into a Victoria's Secret Angel and she
could look like that
yeah he won't call me back yeah so lying
on a dating app really is not gonna help
you like that's really setting yourself
up for failure but also like on the date
he was super nice like he you know
ordered us drinks he ordered us food and
like conversation was kind of easy but
over time as the day was going on I felt
like he was laughing too hard at
everything I was saying or like he was
trying so hard to be like oh we're so
funny right like together don't we yeah
and I was just like what after a while I
was like oh at first I was like oh we're
both kind of funny we have the same
sense of humor but then I kept like
being the one to make him laugh like I
realize he was never really saying
anything that funny to me and then he
was laughing so hard and everything I
was saying and I was just like this is
super weird like he felt it was probably
really nice really fake yeah so it's
just like you I guess you don't have the
confidence number one if you're gonna
lie about your age and then like laugh
so hard at a girl like we all know like
guys don't think women are that funny
usually so you know give me a [ __ ]
break you know he's like really pretty
you're like come on I'm up [ __ ] that
pretty don't think that I don't know
maybe a smile like internal misogyny or
some [ __ ] like that but I'm just like
okay I'm not that [ __ ] funny dude
calm down
you really are [ __ ] yeah you are funny
you were until we played a game of quit
like once and you didn't think it was me
making the answer kept voting for Steve
because I well I mean it was the way he
was laughing too so he was like [ __ ] so
okay so then the other guy like he was
just more like reserved and like like
his reactions seemed appropriate to what
I was saying so I was like he was more
confident with himself and it was like
he wasn't trying it was like either this
works or it doesn't and I'm not gonna
like I love this [ __ ] funny guys who
don't laugh a lot at like jokes yeah you
make them laugh and yeah good genuine
yeah it's like I earned that yeah yeah
that kind of thing so and then I guess
another way to trap me is to like
definitely smell really good and like
clothes on and like hop when it god has
like a very like a manly like leathery
we're not necessarily leathery but I
mean something like man like that kind
of yeah oh that gets well like woody
scent
yeah yeah must have backhoe and wood oh
my gosh like you ever had a guy hug you
that just like smells so manly they're
just like all right like you talk wood
for a living don't you overpowering so
don't put too much on a little whiff of
like oh that's a man subscribe like the
colonial one like the Cologne like like
your heart and he tries like he takes
care of himself from EF candle company
it not sponsored but raising yeah you
should sponsor as because you're amazing
and I love you but there's a scent in
particular called teak wood and tobacco
oh yeah if every guy smelled like that I
don't know what I would do I don't know
what I don't know it's so true Steve
watch out and like I don't know if it's
really a thing for guys but I've never
heard of a guy being like oh I'm gonna
go shop for cologne like girls will do
that with perfume we will go out smell
stuff we want to find like the right
scent and I feel like I don't know maybe
if guys think it's not a masculine thing
to have a like you know to think nature
scent yeah a lot of guys I've dated have
not used Cologne my dad doesn't use
Cologne a bunch of my ex's never use
Cologne but this guy that I saw he was
wearing a cologne and he was like oh yes
this is this is my smell like I
commented on and he's like oh yeah I
always have this smell on and I'm just
like it's almost like the fact that he
thought about that he has like his own
signature scent and like he's it's kinda
like he's just put together yeah yeah I
was just like okay Cologne but he uses a
body wash that's very a lot of times
guys just don't wear it guys okay please
tell us why don't you wear Cologne like
is there like a reason like at least for
Casey like he doesn't work alone but
that's because he wears deodorant and
the deodorant already has like a lot of
like yes which I really like but I'm
like it would be really nice if you also
work alone so I bought him a cologne and
he never wears it I
Steve's natural scent like the
pheromones mixed with like his like body
wash or whatever so some sort of a scent
in there to be overpowering and that's
another thing too like I hate when guys
put like seven [ __ ] sprays yes [ __ ]
on it's like whoa I do not why you in a
public park and you smell like an icon
yeah I need to get like in your personal
space in order to smell it so if I can
smell you from this far away it's too
much only I should be able yeah yeah I'm
not a fan of the axis stuff either oh it
reminds me of high school guys yeah yeah
I do guys wear wear cologne or smell
good
one time my um my boyfriend he was like
oh I think I need a skin care like
regime like he like felt himself getting
just some like fine lines around his
eyes so he bought this like really
expensive skincare set and he was really
excited to show me everything he got I
was like I love this he completely
stopped [ __ ] using it but I thought
it was attractive exactly yeah it's
actually super hot totally I love like a
hygienic dude so Steve also washes his
dick with that same body wash so maybe
it's that association yeah we can't have
sex and like if we are about to have sex
it can never be impulsive or like off
the cuff or spontaneous which kind of
sucks sometimes because he really wants
to be clean down there first which I do
appreciate
yeah that's pretty yeah but yeah there's
that like smell that I'm like wow yeah I
want a second addition to that in
addition to the Cologne thing another
smell thing is a man that actually has
candles in his house and he uses them
I'm like I [ __ ] love this like you
just lit a candle how adorable is that
like Oh smells good and clean yes like a
nice apartment like design interior
design yes it's like oh you actually
know what you lay and yeah it was a
dress yes I have a weird thing not weird
but I really like nerds me I really do
so this guy he's like you'll never look
at like you'll never guess tall muscular
suits right very alpha is it the one
that I met yeah yeah
yukio nerd like I'm talking like comic
book nerd yeah yeah Yukio yeah I'd like
that too but this is like like
competitive yugioh nerd as in like his
card collection isn't a safe know what
I'm talking about the blue-eyes White
Dragon the original one he has like five
of them Wow and like people would kill
for those so when I found that out when
I saw he's like I have something to tell
you I don't know if you're gonna like it
see buddy was all suave and crap boy
yeah yeah businessman Yeah right and he
goes I don't know how to tell you this
but I feel like I should tell you and
then he brought out his binder full
yugioh right and I was just like Gina is
bring by some yugioh cards about it yeah
it's like nerdy cuz I'm all about that
in nerd life yeah like previous of that
I was dating someone in the videogame
industry you know like it was i love
nerds that are passionate about
something that i can relate to
to me it's kind of sounding like there
really is no specific way to really trap
someone somebody either you fit or you
don't but also basically just like if
you're a loser human and you don't have
your [ __ ] together there's no way you're
gonna get a boyfriend or a girlfriend
like you have to just take your ownself
and yeah level up the person just kind
of like be into things you have to like
take care of yourself have ambitions
like it's really and it's like there's
even if you really like someone and you
met so when you're like oh I really want
him how do i trap him it's kind of like
at the same time you're only gonna trap
them if you really wants to be trapped
too but yeah you have to have your own
confidence just to be like I don't
actually need to trap like applying for
a job like you have to actually perform
the job like you can't just lie on your
resume
this has been like an hour-long deep
dive on being yourself ever felt like
like as we move through life and we've
learned my lessons that you learn like
you remember old phrases you heard the
trolleys were like oh that's so act
yeah well every day in school they would
make us say at the end the announcements
make it a great day or not it's your
choice
and I just like always thought that was
really whack and then I was like as an
adult of mine wait a minute because some
morning some mornings I wake up and be
like what kind of day are we gonna have
today Bo's day a good day and like you
know something like that what but be
yourself is something that like it's so
true yeah and I think that when like you
know Nicky and I have said that we were
really big people pleasers before it
that bleeds into dating and it's like
gross and I we don't like when a guy is
obviously trying too hard a guy that was
laughing to our to my jokes I was just
like [ __ ] gross dude Oh as you can
tell it's a front you see them participe
it has to fit and it has to fit
authentically organically like
everything you're trying to do really
you don't need to try to do it again and
like how we were talking about how we
were too available before class I think
is the whole fake it - you'll make it
kind of thing but it doesn't work that
usually crashes and burns when it comes
- yeah like dating someone and when you
actually have to show who you are that's
you should be it before you even put
yourself out there for that there's also
so there's the fake it till you make it
camp and then there's also things called
be do have where you be the thing you
want to be first then you can do the
things that those people do and then
you'll have the things that those people
have and I really like that one too and
cuz it's less like fake it till you make
it or just like be it like the
embodiment of that type of person you
know how they say like if you want to be
sexy
don't try to be sexy like sexiness is
like a it's like a comes from a
confidence within ya so in like
embodying like that and then just
letting it shine it's funny you say that
because when I think about sexiness I
could see the most beautiful
in the world but if she's making a face
like yeah it's not sexy but if the same
exact woman is like smoldering like
snatch like and like she looks super hot
now she's sexy like sexiness is kind of
a mindset it's not you're hearing a lot
of it isn't Minds the way they carry
themselves like there's young people
where I'm like dude like when I saw like
a picture of them I was like whatever
but then the way they carry themselves
I'm like wow that's a sexy person do I
or the opposite they can look really hot
and they're still photo that's what the
online dating that's a huge thing like
in person their energy is like not sexy
slumped oh yeah you can just like feel
the insecurity there was a there's a
celebrity that we work without weight I
can say well okay one that I didn't
think was that attractive and then like
when we met them we were like oh my god
yeah Trevor Noah
like watch The Daily Show and I [ __ ]
loved him we knew like see em in person
tall like shoulders back
like really confidently Shakespearean
smells good perfectly he's just like so
confident and like and everyone's like
whoa didn't expect this like it's like a
mindset and it comes from being
comfortable with yourself and you're not
worried about like do they like me or
not yeah the biggest thing it's just a
lesson okay with you the less you worry
about whether they're gonna like you or
not like the more they're probably gonna
like you like chef without being an
[ __ ] but just like don't worry about
it so much
what you doing Trevor knows yeah
all of us want you here I want to smell
you the repitch Alma's oh definitely
wear this suit oh no actually I want you
wear pajamas too grey sweats that show
everything let us know what makes your
heart swoon what traps you and how
you've trapped other people like what
quality about yourself is like something
that people find well to don't have to
tune in next time to find out subscribe
also shout out to all our sponsors today
door - you could go get five dollars off
of order of $15 or more when you
download the door - app enter promo code
big mood we also got Buffy boses
favorite cannot live without my -
trapped her trapped her real hard visit
Buffy CO and enter mood to get $20 off
your first Buffy comforter we also got
honey app can save you a lot of money
and stitch fix get your style on I'll
get in those pants and maybe someone
will try to get in your pants yes a mood
mm-hmm we need a new sign up temporary